un mois soit souverainiste des élections
fédérales c'est pas quelque chose qui me
longtemps ni beaucoup intéressé d'antan
pour l'instant je sais même pas pour qui
je voterai même le bloc québécois c'est
quelque chose qui m'a rejoint beaucoup
toute la démarche qui s'est faite sur le
niqab se savoure changé de voie pour
parle pas assez de finances il ya des
partis qui ont fait leur temps
il y en a d'autres que l'option en fait
leur temps à nadeau qui ont fait leur
temps gouvernement et ce car bling si
j'ai bien compris un registre où alerte
ps ça fait de la peine qui sont en perte
de vitesse que si ma voix des partis oui
je vous avais pas le cas pour moi ça
fait dire à peu près de 12 ans je suis
ici avec boeing jamais personne parler
d'élection jamais de photos
tout le monde est assez indépendant puis
c'est pour les garçons rémi garde qui
gardent leur rétention d'eau chaude
licka sur les autres discutent jamais de
mots clés mais pas avec les familles